this is a like a miracle
they've rehearsed this for eight years
they started shooting this an extraction
one
[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation we're
gonna watch extraction two today joined
by koi genre Coy how you feeling I love
extraction one so much and I've been
waiting for this for so many years too
haven't even seen the trailers for it I
haven't either but I hear there's a
really long Wonder in this ladies and
gentlemen extract that like button do it
right now and as always full length and
watch along where you sync up with your
own copy of extraction 2 available for
super sexy Rejects at our patreon page
cover so much stuff exclusively over
there with reaction highlights and watch
along concluded cool you excited to jump
into the Sam Hargreaves one of my
favorite new directors and Chris
Hemsworth is Chris Hemsworth so I am so
ready
okay
[Music]
somehow it being Chris Hemsworth makes
me think he could actually survive that
just because oh yeah he's not Jeremy
Renner come on
about
I take uh yearly trips to Dubai oh yeah
on my first class plane oh just to check
in just checking weekend trip
I like that extraction it's the French
film
[Music]
I actually like that we're getting this
we could have just John Wicked it yeah
no I like that he's a human let him be
he had to recover and work his way
through there through resilience looks
genuinely painful thanks Nick
for keeping me around
really excited about this next chapter
of my life
now that's pretty difficult to let
someone you care about die
oh he knows the feeling would you afford
your way back
you just have to find out why to kill
more people
this is like Shaw
it's a fast and furious films guys
family
oh homie
[Music]
oh he's the Reaper
my man looking good look at this what's
with the shirt those are bed or
something you like it no
[Laughter]
what about my dog oh we ate her too I'm
joking she's in the house
so what am I supposed to do now
eat your dog
[Music]
I like how these movies do these Action
Hero tropes like this could have been
the start of the first movie you know
those like 80s action movies where
they're like I'm retired I've gone
through it and I'm recovering you don't
even know why
ha ha hahaha
[Music]
must be the absolute worst losing your
kid cannot imagine
I just registered that he's staying at a
cabin in the woods oh it's all come full
circle Hemsworth
[Music]
it's gonna become fat Thor I just love
that he loves chicken it's like what a
great character thing
foreign
[Music]
the fact that they locked up his whole
family for him is like such a villainy
yeah being buried with someone
distraction three
60 year old Hemsworth takes on this kid
yeah
this is beautiful amazing did not know
foreign
I'm so happy
friend who's offered you a job
I don't have any friends yeah well this
particular individual seems to think
you're the only one that can do it yes
I'm not so convinced can you even put a
trigger like that
and that's why you haven't got any
would you go back and tell her I've sent
you I'm not interested
what if it was your ex-wife
was it or is it just a hypothetical I
mean is it just asking just curious but
her sister is she's currently in a
Georgian prism of her two kids her
husband's locked her in there can you
imagine that call themselves The nagazi
if it wasn't for the Americans to have
it to be free love movies like this I'd
want to get in there nice and quiet keep
my head down Ken you can rest assured
that his brother's going to want to
throw everything at you and I'm talking
about the home the gazi Army oh this
would be good I was so excited this
should be good job starts in six weeks
we take our cut if all goes well you
don't get caught or shot in the face
I'll meet you on the other side and give
her a kiss I hope he gets action scenes
I can only see him as Luther when he has
a popped collar like I just solved with
the recruit Thor
why did they come to you haven't you
heard Nick
I'm a bit of a legend now
I tell you what the job is and when and
how you do it
you also told me to find the reason I
fought my way back let's find out
specific children rescue missions
it's what I do yeah I love an
implausible plot Underdog evil villainy
I like it's all the things I want
training montage yeah Rocky 4 style
what's happening oh there he is
the show Limitless on Disney Plus
thank you
well that arm cast was really holding
him back really was that goes this is
almost last two hours
doesn't need six weeks
we should be able to tell when we're our
winner right oh there's no way we won't
I assume it's gonna be a prison Runner
okay because I think they're gonna find
him and then the whole way out one
I'm ready koi it's happening I'm ready
ready for him to kill a bunch of
prisoners we just learned they were bad
he did some push-ups cut up some logs
threw an ax he's ready to go muscle
memory
this Rock's over there now I'm ready
badass he is so badass he is so cool
yeah he's so badass
uh-oh where does his son's loyalties lie
oh
smart mom
yikes
sorry kid
[Music]
rise from the dead
I think we're in the water is this it I
think so I feel it
I think so you're right let's go water
our water sense was tingling that was
early it's early it's an early water
dammit
hitting cut
I saw it unprofessional
dumbass
[Music]
nice
that sound design
so exciting
on it did I just kill everyone at this
point
[Music]
foreign
good boy
kind of worried the mom's gonna die yeah
she's pretty great and that worries me
yeah
that's part of a video game oh
no oh
it'll happen oh
[Applause]
ouch gosh I feel so painful
ah
yes yes
I hate this split thingy it's really
painful it's no growth oh not a fan
not a fan
we what happened down there trouble
where's my father come on come on
he's fine
he's waiting for you outside he's
waiting free yeah
[Music]
how they did that lift so smooth
it's cool how we're like going around to
different players yeah holy [__]
holy [__] we're doing a full-on prison
right this is crazy
Charlie that isn't through the common
yard
s there must be another way stay close
to me right how about nobody's side
everyone die
all right dude she's the the greatest
video game partner truly
[__]
just starts Ryan
God damn what impressive ass
choreography
two-person video game fight
whoa oh
God
he's awesome
oh
[Music]
laughs
beautiful oh it's so impressive this is
still the same shot
ouch
yeah
yeah oh this is so impressive
God damn it
[Laughter]
whoa how did they transition into this
shot cause it's locked on his stomach
what they like how did they want to do
that what did I walk on
[Music]
how did they do that this doesn't make
any sense
oh my God we've added fire he's on fire
now the star test fire he's here's
enough flaming fist
how do you choreograph fire in a water
he's gone
[Music]
oh
dude
I have so much adrenaline
that was awesome
yeah you guys are doing great
the way they transition these locked off
shots is like blowing my mind it is so
it's not like what how do you leave it
I love the tension of this kid that's
gonna betray us I know
[Music]
I love it just like a video game we're
in the car now how
got it can't get rid of these guys
already on it
I mean how did they just do that these
these like hidden cuts are phenomenal
because I can't see them damn it I've
seen maybe two yeah
oh my God I love it
I'm so happy right now I've got
goosebumps they keep going down and
coming back up back up
here soldiers these men are killers yeah
so am I
there we go this guy should have
directed The Uncharted movie oh man
damn
this is nuts
it doesn't even look like drones like
it's like destroying camera work how did
we just do that shot
ah
the glass can only hold for so long
there's such great CGI in this if the
old school like Fincher thing going
through Windows doing it so well yeah
yeah it blends perfectly
ah so badass
[Music]
oh the girls hurt yeah
it's it's your new family Tyler they
found him now it's a foot chase we've
got so much yeah we've gone through so
many different kinds of actions
he was punching people with fire not
five minutes ago
[Music]
get these extras out of here the
infusion of extras makes it so much more
re-depth yeah adding in the human
element oh there's so much foreground
play to add tension
now we're going on a train
really
every type of automobile is this the
rest of the movie is a water this is
like a miracle
they rehearse this for eight years they
started shooting this an extraction one
we've added helicopters Greg I'll have a
shot at the helicopters just in case I
gotta go
oh my God oh my God yes oh my God he's
going Stallone first Blood get it
oh my God yes
what is this video game
Sam Hargrave direct everything
oh my God
oh what was that guy doing he was a good
guy what was he doing I think he I think
he got hit from down the way okay
oh my God yeah
oh lady I forgot how hot you were she is
awesome
oh man close combat knife gunfights
oh
God
her reaction to the pain feels so real
it's so much
coming
the location that we're going like 80 in
a tiny room
this choreography is so inspiring
yeah whoever shot this like the physical
DP it's like a video game cutscene
Legend
oh
great great
little boy don't trust him you're good
better than him
what are you gonna do so you gotta jump
is he gonna jump
what a badass
yes secure the family we've got no price
oh no it snaps speed on a train somehow
this is gonna segue into a Kaiju fight
I figured foreign
oh it's over it ended on a train roll
like it's a good way to end it oh
damn how long was that like 85 minutes
I'm so tired
that was so long but it it's stayed
engaging throughout they had so much
variety every type of action a slow burn
start to like have a little character
moment man that was a whole movie's
worth of action yeah let's turn it off
that's good thanks we don't know who
this other brother's gonna do he's got
nothing proof there's no Warner coming
in with him no deal with them
Oscar Isaac
the one that designs ex machina yeah oh
I love this guy
it's one of these 87 North guys yeah
yeah yeah they're talking about she said
it was an extraction
two that scar is so cool like the idea
that his face like
that's gonna go that is one of the might
be the greatest action scene sequence of
the year it was incredible
bye guy you got a new dad right there
and he's very he's very strong kick your
biological dad's ass kill them
did you kill him
did you kill him just lie you have no
attachment to this kid I helped
he was gonna kill your mother okay
now he's gotta watch his back like
that's and should have said nope I would
have just lied just like maybe he's a
bad liar
like no one into your dad he was dead
when I found him I tried to get him out
yeah
[Music]
and she wonders oh damn that's hell
it's down in 45 minutes you have to
break the cycle little boy
this is
need anything
my dad I'm hungry
oh don't do it don't give him a fork
don't give him the phone knife
since when do you speak Jordan
he was married to my sister
that's where the ex-wife thing came in
yeah
I was gonna tell you
[Laughter]
Tyler your nephew's a punk don't trust
him not really nephew anymore
step nephew half nephew myself you're
almost free
I'm gonna get you guys someplace safe
okay I promise
this better lead to a great action scene
Ross I'm just gonna stay mad at you I
hate this kid
son of a [__]
come on little man break the cycle
listen I don't know what's your sister
must think of me and there's nothing I
can do to fix that
I just want you to know that it's the
most awful thing a parent can endure
watching a child die
or surpass you financially and not help
you out
oh I'm still like reeling can you
imagine they put this in the theaters
Netflix Netflix killing me people just
be melted into the receipts
40x just punching your spine
I wouldn't have said no
to this
it was important to you
it is
trying to get back in with his wife
this is the way it's the long game
gotta start a small Cold War get her
back
alone I mean this movie is so cool
looking it's only supposed to stay with
his father a good father wouldn't make
him yeah well it's my father didn't
leave us
does he know who Tyler really is it
seems like it seems like a very pointed
Jab
one little hoist Chris
see if a kid lose a kid still safe
trying to try to Pat him on the back Pat
him a little too hard fell over here
she died she stayed with your father for
years to keep you safe
I'm not gonna lie to you mine shit's
gonna get harder from here but you're
gonna have to take care of her she's
gonna need you so you can be there for
her like she was for you I'll let your
father's lives consume you father's
lives are gonna come knocking any second
now it's on you mate
tell him tell Tyler what you did give
him a head start I'm sorry
no
he's coming
oh
we gotta move
I found this because of your son your
son screwed up he covered up oh no she
knows she knows
oh no
now he has to know
how do they know what floor I'm guessing
they tracked the phone
helicopters like let's get out of here
he has known to shoot at helicopters as
much jokes as we make I actually I do
get where the little boys oh sure he
grew up in it yeah man yeah most people
are complaining about us have not made
it to the point where we reveal that we
understand excuse us we get it as well
yeah but we do get it
Nick stain radio contact okay but my
understanding for the kid has the limit
yeah there's a line he just got shot at
yeah
yeah damn look at this big guy
whoa whoa
damn
just an ankle he's going to the back
alley
come back here come back to your mother
your mother did all of this to protect
you come back
I mean you made this far kid might as
well go with your uncle be evil
[Music]
oh my God
did they just kill her I think they
might have
how did she survive that
oh
looks like it'd be so fun to train for
this movie they must have been insane
learning all these movements
whoa oh damn
everyone earlier to engage
damn he barely even took a second aim he
is very good at the missile launcher
oh
he aimed the helicopter or Chris
Hemsworth
man even the bad guys are so well
trained
the beautiful sets to destroy didn't
even flinch
them sugar quit
there's nothing to be sorry about
getting you out of here okay I'm gonna
get you back to your sister just make
sure she hears about this
I really miss her
let her know tell her very Vivid details
thousands of people died for us to get
back together lots of police
[Music]
how did he rig that that was cool
I got this go
I I keep getting where she's gonna die
it's her she said I got this you don't
say I got this
[Music]
weights
ouch
oh
nice there we go there we go oh
[Music]
Jeff
's coming of a nice shot they killed
buff Perry nimrov yeah
treadmill
oh
mind blowing he's gonna slide past her
oh he's shooting just blow himself down
oh yes that was genius
oh
we're going to enjoy killing you yeah
get in line oh
yeah I must really care for this woman
no no it feels to lose someone in love
whoa
trust me should I not
oh [__]
oh the old dumbbell toss right back into
the gym
kettlebell swing I wouldn't even be like
do you trust me I would just throw her
she had an ax on him
oh the big guys we gotta put them like a
500 bullets the big guys
oh or just one headshot gotta got him
first
wow this is a terrifying action scene
foreign
[Music]
uh his way Dad
um way dead yeah okay stay with me buddy
I've got you I got you yeah
oh I liked him yeah
he must have the biggest headache right
now
pain pain
everyone is in so much pain Robbie had
pain right now I said nothing worse than
a headache except a hole in the hand man
I don't know man that is pretty rough
that I had to slow you down even more
she's like really is
oh
no way
not even say hi I was that was very
awkward do you have any idea what he's
done it doesn't get through the details
he killed a man with a leg press machine
to keep her alive if that doesn't win
you back
that's not
you're gonna push him
oh
this is
Dumbo
Mulan Eddie Murphy
foreign
come on man you gotta be smarter than
that he's been that his whole life you
should have seen that even I saw this
coming I've known you guys for 20
minutes I mean come on lifetime of this
oh
the imagery though
maybe he just had enough
oh even now he could deliver cold and
cool lines yeah right yeah
what is
no he's betrayed you
[Laughter]
it's a traitor sorry McDonald's
gotta mess you up got a lot of people
killed him
should have been there for years
I don't want to hear it
but you want to hear about the moving
train and the helicopter
I love this because it's the ultimate
Betrayal on both parties like like what
he did is Unthinkable but we're also
like he just did a lot like
it's such a good conflict
I didn't
it's a great line it's a very real one
yeah exactly it's a summation yeah
why don't you tell me where you are and
we can finish what we started I want to
negotiate I'm not coming to negotiate
what did he say I'm not coming to
negotiate it's a straight up Stallone
Arnold movie from the 80s so and it 100
is that I felt the same way just with
better special effects it's just like
water but with modern day sensibilities
is how they do it I love it with like a
John Wick sensibility and stuff like
yeah with the 87 North team and
everything like yeah man it's cool but
like both of these movies are
exceptional action movies
stay with her get them out open the door
she's got revenge too she has revenge
too you could have let her revenge
[Music]
wow that was a lot louder than I expect
very intense with a little like
a little sniper little flare gun
explosion
[Music]
that was so dope
oh
damn this is so cool
[Music]
oh no where was he shot
oh gut shot no no we need an extraction
three don't give us another fake out
death
oh it's gonna end in a church symbolism
God fathers Sons original sin guilt
architecture
okay
[Laughter]
come
Jesus
sometimes there's a great sacrifice in
an acting God's will
kid pull the trigger consume yourself in
a lifetime of guilt he already lives
that way
oh he's gonna make up children
what is it
smooth
ie
yes well you can exact retribution for
your brother but it will be at the cost
of his life right now
it's on the girl how did he know they
were brother and sister racist
that racism comes in handy sometimes
laughs
[Music]
no no no
oh no
Vita's face to a pulp beat him today
don't like it all the hardware store
deaths they should have finished
building this church you have so much
tetanus
oh
the Home Depot paint is real please
don't tell me there's a bunch of needles
there must be something it's gonna hurt
to watch oh man
oh
I don't even know what that is it's a
lot of weight it's a lot of stuff on a
chain yeah yeah oh
[Music]
[Applause]
climb him yes chunk by chunk climb him
like Everest
oh
just do one little shot to the Head yes
exactly that's exactly what I wanted
exactly how I wanted it to go
how I imagined it at all yeah
no please don't kill her that's a death
that would get me mad at movie
right on time the other authorities I
hope his ex comes in with like a bridal
outfit they're in the right location and
she's ordained
prison I'm like who's in prison
[Music]
why are they all in prison what did I
miss I guess they did a lot of stuff in
foreign soil they get in prison for that
[__] I mean law order
you just did say if he doesn't get out
of there it's on him no law but maybe he
just helps that's right we forgot what
the big risk was the whole time prison
and he was so brave Tyler when it ended
he said
to be brave like
that's how he saw you
goodbye Tyler
I wonder if we got a cameo in this
prison I feel a cami don't you get a
cameo sense coming like a big big end of
movie Cameo yeah I feel like a cameo is
kind of Ryan Reynolds it's always Ryan
Reynolds I suspect someone else
no it's ears yeah I told you not to get
cool
[__] happens huh
what if I could get you out how does
that work
come and do another job for us
no without my team I'm not leaving her
behind
the whole team is here
to survive members
my name doesn't matter
no it does Mr Nobody
who I work for
it was a naughty mother
now we got a franchise set up yeah we do
first one was a open-ended now this is a
we got a franchise
[Music]
yeah sweet digs
oh Joe Russo wrote this one oh [__]
all right Story by Joan Anthony produced
by John Anthony Joe wrote it all right
koi are you going to the bathroom are we
talking I got this let's do it we're
talking let's talk I say we talk this is
a really bright sweater it is and it
looks great I didn't realize how bright
it was I'm glad you noticed an hour and
48 minutes in right now
um yeah wow what a what an experience I
mean I feel like this is one of those
movies that's made for reaction videos I
am so tense and sore and also
emotionally sore and also
I want to go fight things all of them
things I don't remember the first one
well enough to know if I like it more
than the first one I Remember Loving the
first one and I love this one but I
don't know I love more they're both
coming from a place of Love yeah yeah I
feel like this took it more in the
direction that it probably wanted to be
I don't okay
I yeah I don't I just don't remember the
details enough of the first one I
remember David Harbor surprised me in
the first one and Idris Elba surprised
me in this one well okay look it goes
without saying the action is just as
phenomenal as always and I my one
concern was when we had such an epic
Runner
that is this movie about to get like
boring oh sorry I defended the casting
for this too hey my one concern was is
this movie gonna get boring like you get
such a high from so early on in this
movie yeah and what is that like 20
minutes it's like 20 it was 20 minutes
long at least and and then I'm like okay
is any other action set piece really
good and then it does and then the
action manages to become something
that's more
um they rely more on the emotional
engagement while still having that great
choreography and some cool do you care
about all these people enough that we
were mad at that kid like we were joking
a lot but we understood where he's
coming from because of how good the
writing was exactly when you get to the
whole building sequence uh yeah you're
on the edge like okay one of our
characters is about to die it's one of
those one of the brothers and sisters
yeah Nick or yes one of them is gonna
die right now I don't know which one
it's gonna be but one of them's dead
yeah uh so yeah like that had me on edge
and I think those sequences are great
the ending sequence is great Nick and
Yaz were so good in this one I I think
it this one might Edge out just because
we were already investing the characters
we didn't have to build them up so for
me I I my instinct is I like this one a
little bit more but I need to re-watch
the first one but I do think
instinctively I think of Nick and Yaz as
like so captivating in this one like
from the jump but I think that's reliant
on the first so I I don't know how I
barely remember them from the first one
at all at the beginning I thought that
and then once we ran I was like all
right I Remember Loving them but like it
definitely took me like the first two
minutes to being like right that did not
happen for me okay I was like
guy I was like is that he's from the I
kept going he's from the first floor
yeah so but I found myself endeared to
them
um so yeah the action's phenomenal I
think we've talked plain about it
through I think we've reviewed the
action in the moment every moment really
need to review the action dude
it is epic and uh the like this is one
of those action movies that they ever
released it on the big screen I would
love to like why imagine if they they
did IMAX conversion so sometimes they
play these at iPic it's a it's like a
gourmet restaurant movie theater chain
and you get the word on those and if you
find out you let me know because I want
to see this like that way I would love
to see this specific movie on the big
switch like as I love the John Wick
action because I what's the one thing
about the wonder that I have to ask
myself is okay
is it only one of the best because it's
a runner or does the choreography of
itself compete truly with the job and
that's what I mean the core office has
been incredible but I've seen like
chapter four of John Wick twice so I'm
like okay it's gonna be some somewhere
between John Wick how great is it 2023
I'm like are two of the best action
movies of all time like in like really
the same like two months apart with some
of the same stunties like some of the
same some people were in both well you
see I my same my same like little gripe
that I have with that I I remembered
having with the first one that I still
think carries over here is ah forgive me
for being an [__] what is the
director's name Sam Margaret Sam
Margaret beautiful beer God damn it yeah
yeah I know I see his face and
everything but us Sam Hargrave like
phenomenal action director obviously no
questions asked because even when
there's action here whenever there's
action it is it is emotionally engaging
like it is suspenseful it's more than
just cool it there's a there's a there's
a attention to it I am gripped by the
heart in the moment when it's happening
I still do think the scenes when there's
not action need a little bit of work on
being a little more interested like yeah
the the opposite of this one I I know
you do I can tell that's our big
difference yeah because I'm I'm like
anytime there's a Slowdown I'm like okay
not only do I need this but also I love
these people and then like the the
beautiful moment at the end like I
almost cried like I got emotions I was
really I was real close and it was hurt
like because like because they they
didn't have her forgiveness and I also
like that like I I like that she didn't
forgive him like I also like that she
gave him the gift of forgive yourself I
can't forgive you I still went through
this that's unforgivable for me but I
want you to live your life without that
yo dude I love that I'm 100 on the same
page as you the only my little when I
say a little grip I mean a little grip
because I it's so minor to the point
where I love the action and I only like
this song
yeah like there's I don't love a lot of
the scenes when there's not action like
I'm I'm always I'm not bored I'm I'm
interested and I like the performers a
lot I feel like it's really elevated a
lot by the performances yeah I don't
even I'm not even sure what it really
needs to be it's like because both these
movies have that thing where it's like
it's a very serious it's somber dramatic
tone and then like really cool action
but the action feels really supported
because the scenes leading into it are
really serious so you need that that way
there's emotional heft and a Thrust when
there is the actions is that why you're
pulled into it for for the character
purposes like I totally get the
intention
I don't even know exactly what my wish
is here for it I just know I'm not like
I'm not in love with it like whereas I
can say that for like I can be in love
with scenes like Mission Impossible
movies when there's no action or the
John winter studies I could be in love
with those scenes and here I'm like yeah
this is about like
by the numbers as it is well executed
you know so for me John Wick one two and
four I was invested in the non-action
scenes but I struggled with three and
then it got me back and forth yeah
whereas this one like obviously we're
just comparing because it's the same
year but these two very stylized action
things I feel slightly more emotional
connection I think to
extraction I think the Chris Hemsworth
character is more relatable I also think
he reminds me of what like a modern day
Martin Riggs would be and I love the
Lethal Weapon world like to me he's like
rigs but in like if he'd stayed Special
Forces and I think that's an archetype I
adore and I love John Wick but like
there's something about the the Tyler
rake archetype that I'm all in yeah I
like the way this movie decides to make
an effort to even for its follow-up to
still keep it
a character-driven story within Tyler
Rick because in that one he's grieving
and now he's finding a reason to carry
on yeah and the third one I'm finding a
resolution with his wife in some way I
hope he gets like a new reason to live
in the next one where you like that
closure
and I hope the end of extraction becomes
the three and it goes like and then
there's three
they should just flip the E I also doing
subtractions
what is your fonts I don't care about
the movie
but I also love that the two brothers uh
zarab and David are both played by guys
named tornike yeah well I think I was
also more endeared to the and the first
one I was more and dear to the whole
like again it's all true it's all action
trucks like the Father and Son uh
dynamic in the first one uh that's why I
was like oh God because they had the
Cliffhanger
remember when he Dives in and goes up at
the end and then he sees like the
Obscure Tyler in the bed yeah like that
I wanted to see what happened there I
did and we didn't get that but I like
the brothers here I like the villains
yeah I like the villains I do I think
they're tied like I I can't pick one
because that has been the four years
whatever since I've seen it well I think
aesthetically it's cool too because the
first one is uh where's that the first
one I don't remember I don't know it's
hot and sweaty and icky yeah and here
are just like snowy landscape next time
he's gotta go to a jungle for predator
three do you gotta do the job oh just
green Tyler rake doing jungle stuff I
think they use the environment really
well and I love how the Deep like the
cinematography if I remember that Sam
Harker's background was he a
cinematographer before I believe so I
think he was also a stunt guy I think
he's got
because like him and David Leach are
like these two epic stunties turned if I
remember correctly he's also his stunt
double he had a I remember he had a dick
Hemsworth he had a different profession
prior to I think he was Hemsworth was
that that's how that became friends just
like David Leech was Brad Pitt's I think
we gotta this this Stunt Man actor and
director stunt coordinator yeah I think
he was the stunty for uh for Thor in the
beginning okay that's what it was he
wasn't a um yeah he wasn't a whatever
not a DP but yeah he was like a stunt
coordinator and then Avengers end game
in Deadpool he became the stunt
coordinator from being a stunt man yes
okay and he's an absolute boss uh I've
never been a couple premieres and he's
always like so engaged in how people
move like it's cool to see him look at a
room because he's like tracking there's
the axis like he looks at a room in the
in the way the you know like when you
watch someone how like they turn left or
right and then how it tracks forward
it's cool to watch people that are
stunned people like also navigate like
the distance between you and I yeah like
you can see him like coordinating and
like choreographing in a room like I
love watching stunt coordinators and the
way his directing is very much like
z-axis based yeah because that's how he
sees love this director yeah
um but I really like this I think I like
it more than the first one um this is
some of the best action ever and I feel
like the first one's lost as big of a
film as the first one is I feel like it
kind of got forgotten for how great the
action is in that movie I think it was
my top 10 in that year but I haven't
watched it since which is like you know
that's tricky yeah but the the action
here I feel like they really went up
themselves because the one or in the in
the first one was amazing and then this
one because yeah obviously there's cuts
and [__] but sure the point is to it's
about the immersion experience which it
had we looked and we were still like
yeah
helicopter walk-offs chest lock off like
how did they do any there was a fire
punching sequence I think it's really
great too because Chris Hemsworth is
like one of the only actors to have
become famous via the MCU and has
managed to find film a film work outside
and he's got this extraction franchise
uh which he excels in he's so happy
fourth grade in this role like yeah more
than just the action scenes like he
really carries this performance he might
be the most successful of the core I
think so as out of the ones who became
famous through and then have managed to
do stuff outside of it yeah I think so
because like like a lot of people have
carried on as they were before the MCU
he's elevated his career so not to
disparage Anyone But like everyone else
has stayed at a level he like used it in
a really wonderful way like he's got
that nice Middle Ground where yeah you
know him as Thor but you don't only want
to see him as Thor and I'll go see a
Chris Hemsworth movie I don't
necessarily feel that way about everyone
yeah and we will not specify who to be
next just saying Chris Hemsworth I will
see his name
also Joe and Anthony Russo I will see
their movies uh Sam Hargreaves I will
see like there are certain like things
that came out of the MCU that are live
now like diverging Paths of excitement
yeah I appreciate the extra effort that
this franchise gives specifically uh
this movie too but they're having some
more of his like religious undertones
and having the whole for a movie about a
grieving father to be having this uh
generational trauma cultural trauma as
well yeah to be [__] into here I I
respect the fact that they actually make
the concerted effort again it's more
like uh yeah I I don't I still don't
quite know what it what it is I could
use a little bit more zest to it or
something a little more unique in it
because it kind of It kind of just does
play by the numbers for me it's one of
the things I find Charming about these
two films is they're like an 80s
but I get what I want I still feel like
it could go a little bit of the extra
mile to enhance the screen
ultimately I get what I want that's the
thing is like I don't want to harp on it
too much I'm just I'm harping on it only
because I'm like what am I looking for
here uh because yeah at the end of the
day would I show up for more than
delivers in ways that are Beyond
satisfactory like I would give this
movie I would still meet you at four and
a half stars out of five I would still
totally meet you I think yeah I think
we're both I think I'm just saying it in
an affirmative and you're just saying
looking for negative I'm just saying
look it's everything I want you're like
it's everything I want and that we're on
the same page it's just like the one
thing that we just
up a little bit more it's just what can
we do with some of those uh
the Forgiveness that she gives him like
I feel like it's gonna have that you
know what it was that Idris Elba scene
brought something different for me
um you know like having a little bit
more of that variation yeah like Idris
Elba I think brings a lot of that that
little spice to it oh immediately you
know and as soon as you see him on the
porch you're like this could be good
because there is sort of this like super
soft like both these movies have that
let's just super somber series then he's
just so quick but to have a bit of that
variation allows the somberness to even
have more effect when you got a little
bit more variety in your scenes and I
feel like Idris Elba brings that variety
again another very tropey character but
that that but throwing that into the mix
allows for uh more of an emotional
appeal for me so yeah I'm excited for
interceptible to be in here and to have
further enhancement great music great
designs overall
um yeah this movie more than delivered
excellent action film bring on
extraction very pleased cannot wait so I
didn't watch the trailer Idris was a
great surprise very excited for
attention so happy didn't watch the
trailer same so happy koi I gotta get
you out of here yep you got two minutes
so before we do I just really want to
quickly do a patron of the day shout out
Andrew Hayes if I ever needed someone to
help me extract someone from a prison it
would be Andrew Hayes because the guy's
like five foot one and he's stocky and
bulky and he could be like beat up
people punch them in the knees and stuff
you can get him through vents go through
crowds crawl on through people's legs
and that are spread open if so if he has
to rescue a child he would be the
perfect person to pull off the ultimate
Tyler straction experience so Andrew my
friend we gotta go out there we gotta
save some lives and by we I mean I show
up to your door and be like I'll split
the profits with you you get 30 I get 70
go in there hand some business and thank
you for never pledging and never hitting
us up on patreon either don't know how
much he thinks 5-1 is but that's not
knees but I'm very confused by his
height scale five one will make it
easier duck in between players all right
extract are you five one I'm five eight
and a half five nights I'm a little bit
offended there under six footer we gotta
defend our fellow under six Footers
between seven foot five one I'm closer
to five one
respect see you guys
[Music]